bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france à leurs jours d'élections au
chili la fois à présidentielle
législatives et régionales
quels sont les différents enjeux de ces
scrutins
l'enjeu est considérable
on est effectivement dans un moment clé
de l'histoire chilienne à deux ans de la
grande révolte qui avait eu en 2019 il
ya une assemblée constituante en tout
cas une nouvelle constitution qui en
cours de rédaction et le président
sortant votre reportage l'a bien dit est
vraiment au plus bas dans les sondages
et une grande crise de légitimité de la
politique en général des parties et donc
pour les chiliens il ya un vote
important qui va permettre de savoir est
ce que coûtent les demandes sociales qui
se sont exprimées depuis deux ans vont
commencer à avoir un début de réponse
même si aussi beaucoup de désillusions
et l'abstention il faudra regarder de
près ce sera probablement assez forte et
on l'a dit également dans le sujet il ya
deux candidats deux favoris 1 qui se
détachant pour la présidentielle les
candidats que tout opposait ce que c'est
le symbole de la fracture politique au
fini oui c'est une traduction différée
de cette polarisation et de sept
divisions de la société chilienne
gabriel boric de la gauche et du centre
gauche qui revendique quand même mettre
fin à toute une partie de l'héritage
de la dictature du néo libéralisme
démocratique il ya eu depuis 90 qui a
une critique très forte sur le modèle de
développement et de l'autre un candidat
d'extrême droite qui revendique
ouvertement
pineau chez mais surtout qui incarne une
demande d'ordre d'ordre xénophobe
d'ailleurs et qui est prêt à militariser
le sud du pays par exemple contre le
peuple mapuche donc là il ya deux
visions ou qui s'incarne et qui sont en
opposition assez frontal donc
effectivement l'issue du scrutin sera
capital pour savoir dans quelle
direction le chili va aller et sera d
impact
you know latino américains assez
important également il y aura forcément
selon vous à l'issue de ce scrutin une
rupture avec la politique actuelle
alors là c'est là où les difficultés
commencent
entre les discours et les pratiques il
faudra voir dans quelle mesure si pour
l'instant le favori des sondages étant
gabriel boric donc gauche centre gauche
est capable véritablement de mettre en
oeuvre son programme est capable
d'incarner les forte demande sociale de
plus d'égalité de plus de services
publics de moins de marchandisation de
l'éducation de la santé dans un pays qui
reste d'une part fragmenté et d'autre
part ou une partie des élites sont très
conservatrices très hostile à tout
changement un peu disent on est donc là
les difficultés sont là et même si caste
donc l'extrême droite perd elle est bien
installé dans le pays et compte bien
continuer à se construire dans les
années à venir alors vous parliez 1 du
taux de participation qui va être
scrutée de très près il ya également
deux choses qui va être suivi c'est le
vote 1 de la jeunesse on a vu un aussi
dit on à une jeunesse très déterminé
tout à fait la jeunesse était au coeur
en fête des grandes mobilisations
sociales pas seulement depuis 2010 neuf
il faut se rappeler les grandes
mobilisations étudiantes au des lycéens
de 2011 et cette jeunesse cette nouvelle
génération qui n'a pas connu la
dictature
elle compte bien se faire entendre
d'ailleurs pas forcément dans les urnes
il ya toute une frange de la jeunesse
qui rejette le système électoral au
général mais qui est politisé très
politisée et qui va continuer à se
mobiliser même si là aussi il ya des
difficultés la pandémie la crise
économique actuellement au chili est
très très forte et ça aussi ça d impact
sur le vote et sur les formes de
mobilisation des jeunes aujourd'hui
franck gaudichaud merci d'avoir être
avec nous en direct sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur en
histoire et civilisation de l'amérique
latine contemporaine université toulouse
jean jaurès merci à vous